six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go next to our caller from the 575
area code caller from 575 who's this
where are you calling from hi there
David my name is Kevin I'm calling from
San Diego California what's going on
well I worked with someone that believes
that a border wall is necessary for
keeping out that dangerous illegal
immigrants and he's resistant to facts
but I try to provide about how the wall
is not good it's not a good idea and
that if it done is done it'll be
expensive to maintain and it's not like
a one-and-done cost yeah and to the fact
that illegal immigrants in the country
didn't come through an illegal border
border crossings most people came in
through planes and everything and then
overstayed a visa right I know would be
probably better just to ignore the guy
and focus on people that are more
reasonable but I think kind of have to
work with them so what do you think it
could say that would be likely to make
him like reconsider decision I mean it
sounds like this person's pretty far
gone so I think your your primary
instinct of just ignoring this person at
least on this issue is your best one but
let's indulge in it a little bit maybe
you could try the Socratic method of
questioning or the de feasibility
question you could say what information
if you found out that it was the case
would make you think that the border
wall is a bad idea right because it's if
they if they grant conceptually that the
border wall could be a bad idea like you
could say I understand that you think in
our particular circumstances the wall is
a good idea is it possible that a wall
in the abstract could be a bad idea and
if he says that's not possible then you
need to end the conversation immediately
but assuming that he has some kind of
common sense he would say yeah it's
possible that in some situation the wall
wouldn't make sense so then I would
follow up and I'd say okay what are the
circumstances which if they were real
would make you think the wall is not a
good idea and see what they say if they
have nothing then they're not really
dealing with fact they're dealing with
faith and then there's really nothing to
talk about but that's maybe the approach
I would take yeah it always seems
somebody's doing the thing where they're
taking something on safe
you always say like you know just end
the conversation there but it seems like
I don't know I want to go and like say
to that person like can't you see that
that's a bad thing that like but I don't
know I guess yeah there's yeah that some
people have to that would be what else
in your life do you take on faith and
trying to create the appearance that or
getting them to realize that they're
applying a different degree of scrutiny
to most things in their life except for
this and that maybe that's indicative of
the fact that they're only thinking
about it emotionally and not factually
right that's a possibility yeah which
really sucks yeah all right well good
luck with that let us know how it turns
out doesn't doesn't sound like a good
situation